It's great to welcome to the program today,
Isaac Bogor, who is an infectious diseases
and scientists based out of the university
of Toronto and Toronto general hospital.
The topic today is of course Corona virus.
So great to have you on.
I appreciate your time.
Of course.
So to start with right now, the, the latest
numbers that I'm seeing are somewhere around
82,000 cases.
There's a question Mark as to whether there
are about 15,000 more in China that are not
part of that official record.
Would want to hear from you a little bit about
your thoughts on that approaching 2,800 deaths.
So in context based on the current world population,
how does this rank right now in terms of how
deadly this is and how widespread this is?
Yeah, I mean both very important questions
and kind of separate questions as well in
terms of how deadly it is.
You know, if we look at the current numbers,
you'll see, you know, this 2% case fatality
rate also known as mortality rate number.
That's used pretty frequently.
The question is how accurate is that?
And really it's not entirely clear if that
number is entirely reflective of the full
spectrum of illness.
What I'm trying to say is there's probably
a lot of people that have this infection that
just are not sick enough to seek medical care
and the true denominator of people infected,
there's probably a lot greater than what we
see.
So that 2% mortality rate might actually go
down a little bit as we have a greater appreciation
of how many people are infected.
And that kind of leads us to the next point.
How much of this infection is out there?
It's interesting.
I feel, I feel like we have to timestamp every
conversation because you know, as of February
26, 2020 there seems to be a growing number
of countries that are reporting cases and
within countries that have known chains of
transmission of this infection, there are
a growing number of cases in most of these
places.
So if we're not calling this a pandemic now,
we'll likely be calling it a pandemic in the
days to come because that's exactly where
this is headed.
So one, two of the charts that I, that I have
in front of me are total cases and total deaths.
And when you look at those two graphs on a
linear scale, total cases has started to flatten
out as of about February 15 meaning that the,
the number of new cases seems to be growing
more slowly.
Uh, total deaths has started to flatten out,
but only over the last few days.
How relevant is it to look at that graphical
representation of the cases in thinking about
where this is potentially going next?
Yeah, I mean I think we have to appreciate
what the strengths are in the data and what
some of the weaknesses are in the data.
And of course we know that most of the data
to date is from China.
And we know that of course, even with this
expanding, uh, infections wrote many different
parts of the world.
Still the bulk of the cases are in China.
China impose these unprecedented, massive
public health initiatives to really slow down
but not stop but slow down the spread of this
infection.
And of course when we start to see this flattening
out, uh, and maybe even decrease in the number
of cases, uh, maybe that's reflective of actually
not, maybe it's most likely that that's reflective
of these massive public health initiatives
that were imposed in China.
What that data doesn't show you is that over
the last few days, we've had a few other major,
uh, regions that have significant disease.
Auron is one of them.
Northern Italy is another one.
And already we're starting to see exported
cases from those folks.
PSI.
So, you know, I don't think we have a true
understanding of what the actual number of
cases are for this infection, uh, because
a, it's a moving target and B, there's just
a lot of cases that haven't come to, uh, medical
attention or haven't been screened yet.
Uh, this is the kind of thing where at this
point in time as a February 26th, the more
you'll look, the more you find.
So, uh, and this is truly is a, a shifting
goalpost and a rapidly moving, uh, epidemics.
So you know, those data are helpful, but they
don't tell the entire picture by any means
in terms of how this is transmitted.
Um, there's some confusion and there have
been conflicting claims made about both the
origin, the original transmission to a human
and then transmission between humans.
So can you lay out what we know in terms of
how it's transmitted?
Uh, the, whether or not there has been asymptomatic
transmission and anything else that would
be relevant to know about this.
Oh, I'm just going to roll up my sleeves here
now because this is a great topic.
So a couple of things.
First of all, let's talk about how does humans
get this?
So this virus has likely existed for millennia
and, and existed in like, I have to be careful
with my words.
It likely existed in bats.
It was probably, again, careful with the words.
It was probably transmitted from bats to another
nonhuman mammal host.
And then it was probably transmitted from
that other nonhuman mammal host into a human.
Um, that's probably what happened.
And people that know much more about this
who are, you know, genomics and molecular
biologists and geneticists can look at the
virus and look at the similarities of this
virus to other viruses and patterns of that.
But that, that's probably the story.
Of course, we know that it did jump into humans
and we started to hear about a growing number
of cases in Wu Han, China in, you know, mid
to late December.
And of course we all know where we are now.
We're sitting at the precipice of a, of a
pandemic where there's just wide-scale global
transmission of this infection.
So how did we get it from there to here?
It's a respiratory virus and like other respiratory
viruses, it behaves in a very similar manner.
People will have symptoms of a cough, they
can shed the virus through the respiratory
tract and they can cough out the virus and
transmitted directly to people through coughing
and, and uh, and people in that close vicinity
of them.
And also we know that with other respiratory
viruses in the droplets of, uh, which people
are coughing out, there can be virus in that
and that can land on surfaces.
And you know, this virus might be able to
live for a period of time.
Usually it's going to be in hours.
Today's, although for this particular virus,
we don't have that answer yet.
But in general it's hours, two days, depending
on the service, depending on the environment
it's in.
And then if someone else touches that virus
and they know wipes, their eyes wipes their
nose, wipes, their mouth doesn't wash their
hands, they can get the infection that way.
So that's how it's transmitted through direct
contact and through a likely through respiratory
droplets.
You touched on another really important point
and that's what's the deal with asymptomatic
transmission.
It's a bit of a contentious issue.
I mean there certainly have been some very
high profile reports of people who have had
no symptoms whatsoever who are able to transmit
this infection.
Now, in some cases when you scratch the surface
a little bit more, those people were actually
symptomatic, just very mildly symptomatic.
In other cases, they might have truly been
asymptomatic.
But I think a more practical way to sort of
reframe this is rather than dealing with this,
someone truly symptomatic or not, I like to
think of this in terms of, I like the term
subclinical.
What subclinical means is someone has the
infection.
Someone might be shedding virus to it, you
know, either a lot or a little, but however
sick they are, they're not sick enough that
they're going to seek medical care.
They're not sick enough where they say, you
know what, I'm really sick.
I've got to stay home, or I got to seek, seek,
seek healthcare.
So these are tend to be people with no symptoms
or very, very mild symptoms.
And from some of the data that we've had from
this epidemic and actually some high quality
data emerging from China looking at thousands
and thousands of cases.
There's a growing narrative and data to support
this narrative that many, many people have
this who have this infection have actually
a mild course of illness.
So if people have such a mild course of illness
and there's a significant number of people
that have this infection that just aren't
sick enough to seek medical care, they are
going to be transmitting this virus in the
community.
They're going to be transmitting it to other
people.
And that's probably why we're seeing the numbers
that we're seeing now.
How do you ultimately contain something like
this when it gets to a point like the one
that it is now?
In other words, do we have to, is it about
people not traveling around?
Is it really that, is it about, I mean just
what from a public health perspective, what
do we know about when it gets to this point,
how you deal with it?
Right, so containment is not an option.
Containment is not an option.
Now, earlier on in the epidemic, I've said
this a million times, I really first still
firmly believe it, early in the epidemic,
all efforts should have been made and were
made to contain this in China.
But in the same sentence we were saying all
efforts should be made to contain this in
China, but we should be prepared for the scenario
that this cannot be contained in China.
And of course that's where we are now.
And certainly those massive public health
initiatives in China were helpful.
They were extraordinarily helpful.
I mean this impacted about 10% of the world's
population with, you know, mobility restrictions
and whatnot.
Uh, and this really slowed the virus down.
It's not going to stop it, it didn't stop
it, but it certainly slowed down the global
transmission by decreasing the number of exported
cases and decreasing transmission throughout
China, which was extremely helpful because
of probably bought the world, you know, four
or five ish weeks to prepare.
And now the only hope is that people use that
time wisely and really scaled up their public
health systems, their healthcare systems,
their government structures that they use
to deal with infections and epidemics.
Because you know, it's not going to come to
anyone surprised that wherever you are on
planet earth, you will likely be seeing more
cases than what you're seeing now.
So in terms of an individual making travel
decisions, right?
Um, sometimes we see and you start to see
China's got 78,000 cases in South Korea has
1200 or whatever, and people might start to
say, well, these are countries that I would
avoid.
Now at the same time, if you consider influenza
standard flu in different places, you're not
looking at those numbers before you travel
necessarily.
And you also have a risk of contracting flu
when you travel, depending on your age, it's
not likely to kill you much like it seems.
The death rate for Corona virus for those
under 40 is very, very low.
So how should the average person make a travel
decision around this?
Yeah, there's a few points I think that are
important to highlight here.
Number one is everybody's going to have their
own risk aversion, tolerance threshold and,
and of course we have to be humble here.
We don't have all the answers to this infection.
We have a lot more data than we did one and
two months ago, but we certainly don't have
all the answers here and we have to remain
humble that we, we, we just don't know some
things about this virus yet.
The next point is, uh, that people who ultimately
decide to travel should be very cautious about
travel advisories and travel restrictions.
Currently, currently as we have certain countries
that have more of a burden of a greater burden
of infection than others.
We have travel advisories and travel restrictions
to those countries.
Every country is different.
Every country will have their own policy and
these are changing policies right now.
So if you're traveling, I think you have to
be mindful of the country you live in, the
country you're going to and any potential
stops along the way and what the current policies
are in those places.
The second thing I think you have to be mindful
of is there's changing goalposts here.
I mean the who knows what policies might be
enacted or redacted between the time someone
books their ticket to the time someone actually
gets on the plane.
And so I think the third thing is if people
are choosing to travel, I mean I think you
should have some insurance or safety net in
place where for whatever reason, health, uh,
you know, quarantine restrictions, cancellations,
you can get reimbursed for your flights or
your, the money you spent on this trip.
Last thing, when it comes to a vaccine, I've
seen reports that say a vaccine is eight months
away.
I've seen reports that say a vaccine in total
will take two years and that could be closer
to a year and a half away is my instinct is
if we are in a situation in 12 months where
we desperately need a vaccine, it will have
gotten very bad.
Yeah.
I mean there's, the vaccine is, you know,
it takes time, energy, money and brains to
make an effective vaccine.
Uh, and people say, well, look at Ebola in
2014 and the West African epidemic, there
was a deployment of a vaccine there.
But remember, people had decades of effort
that went into the vaccine before it was deployed
in West Africa.
People started looking into a coronavirus
vaccine after SARS and then during Merz.
But you know, these are underfunded, underappreciated
research endeavors.
And of course, now that we're on the verge
of a pandemic, everyone's thought, Oh, we
should really reinvest in this.
But it's, it's gonna take time.
My bet is that it's certainly over a year.
Now.
The point is that if there's, this might be,
this might've run its course by then, in which
case one of the risks is that we just crossed
that off our budget line item.
But this is not the last coronavirus we're
going to see.
Right?
We had SARS, we had MERS, we have coven 19.
This is going to happen again.
You don't need a crystal ball to know that
this is going to happen again.
So all efforts should really be placed on
a vaccine for either, hopefully, you know,
in a, in a perfect world would be available
for this epidemic or pandemic, whatever we
want to call it.
And certainly to prevent the next one
last thing very quickly.
Is it, should we look forward to when it starts
to get a little warmer in certain parts of
the world?
Is it true that that when it gets warmer,
this is going to hopefully diminish in terms
of how, how much it is spreading?
I certainly hope so, but I'm not betting on
that whatsoever.
And you know, we keep hearing that, you know,
Corona viruses, uh, don't do well in, in warmer
climates.
But I also think we have to.
So the short answer is nobody knows.
The longer answer is, you know, sometimes
during the course of an epidemic, a lot of
these rules don't apply.
So for example, influenza is typically, uh,
a winter, uh, uh, winter, uh, infection, but
H one N one started in the summertime and
really spread pretty efficiently in the summertime
and in the winter time.
So you know, I'm not entirely sure if these
rules will apply to this.
Of course.
I hope it does, but uh, I don't think we can
bet on that and we shouldn't be betting on
that.
We should be prepared for an increased number
of cases regardless of what the temperature
is.
Outside.
We've been speaking with dr Isaac Bogart,
who's an infectious diseases physician and
scientist
based at the university of Toronto and Toronto
general hospital.
I really appreciate your time and your insights
today.
Anytime